[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
2009 10 wird ein superjahr wir befinden
uns glaube ich in einer sehr kniffligen
lage gerade unsere welt droht zu platzen
das machen wir natürlich so sogar bis zu
100 gäste groß ist die migration es ist
unzufriedenheit von menschen die abkehr
von universalismus von universalen
wertvorstellungen ich glaube dass mehr
denn je
die leute brauchen kunst ein großteil
von menschen hätte gerne einfache
antworten auf komplizierte fragen und
situationen und entwicklungen und
neuerungen es gibt keine einfachen
antworten
[Musik]
ich will gar nicht sagen dass alles
super duper ist
[Musik]
ja
sogar
wir sind und haben es geschafft ein jahr
liegt hinter uns ein neues vor uns und
das tut der mensch wenn er zur ruhe
kommen will
er ordnet die dinge und schaut sie sich
nochmals an
ein rückblick auf 2008 10 und ein
ausblick auf 2009 10 das gibt's bei uns
heute und zwar in einer bar denn hier
kriegt man immer trost willkommen im
club s inkl
in zürich
matto kämpf ist ein oft gesehener gast
hier im helsinki und zwar nicht nur am
tresen sondern auch auf der bühne der
autor schauspieler satiriker hat
kürzlich ein neues buch herausgegeben
und will damit auch gleich ein neues
genre erfunden haben nennt es ein viel
buch und das passt ja bestens zum januar
groß denn wir momentan spielen motto
kampf mit mir gut als buch immer noch
viel schlechter geht das habe ich doch
bloß und das liest man natürlich mit
großer freude
ich nehme sie haben sich auf ihrem
eigenen bedürfnisse not ruhige machen
was meine schwimm meeresboden mal ganz
ohne ist kann sich wieder abstoßen und
kommt man mit passiert genau die in der
pflege waren wie das neue buch heißt gar
zum 3 kulturjournalisten wo ganz
verzweifelt nach hilfe sind vom laves
und herzlicher dank
sie suche nach dem sinn von laaber
zwischen großem und büro und bartels ich
schaffe wenig sofort fällig haben sie
zudem die druckkraft die realität
natürlich einen großen bereich
ich hab mir das einfach kulturjournalist
wahrheit ein kulturelles und
ja es läuft so wie vor zum klub ins büro
denn weder das erste mal gesehen was
nachher kredite
meine kolleginnen und kollegen
kulturjournalisten also haben man staune
ihre arbeit gemacht und sich versuchte
ein überblick zu verschaffen was bleibt
von 2018 und was kommt auf uns zu was
kommt da auf uns zu raumschiff erde
ziemlich bleibt es daher ein neues jahr
neues glück
kein plan doch erst mal startet homo
sapiens darauf wohl recht selbstbewusst
ins jubiläumsjahr mit blick zurück auf
den moment als er das eroberte
die mondlandungen hat sich zum
fünfzigsten mal ich darf sagen ich bin
zu jung um sie damals miterlebt zu haben
und deswegen habe ich vielleicht jetzt
nicht diese persönlichen erinnerung dass
ich sagen kann ja ich habe mich daran
wie ich damals vor dem fernseher laden
stand und mit 20 anderen leuten das
gesehen habe
genau ein halbes jahrhundert ist es her
da armstrong und aldrin den fuß auf
setzten ihre fahne ins mondgestein
steckten und die welt jubelte schön und
gut nur jetzt 50 jahre später haben wir
unsere eigene bescheidene kugel ganz
schön runter gerockt
die welt ist aus den fugen erobert das
alle hier unten läuft ziemlich schief
viel zeit bleibt nicht mahnte die im
letzten jahr verstorbene physiker
stephen hawking baut eine mondbasis
schickt die menschen zum mars wenn wir
nicht bald das all besiedeln sind wir
verloren klimawandel als der oiden
einschläge epidemien
bevölkerungswachstum künstliche
intelligenz in mutter erde chance könnte
es in absehbarer zeit recht ungemütlich
werden
wenn wohl auch nicht 2019 dann einfach
ein paar jahre später
ich find's gut dass menschen auf dem
mond sind ich find's gut dass man weiter
mal verschossen hätte und er kann sagen
wie der nikolai siry schön
ich bin immer beeindruckt wenn ich sehe
wie weit der mensch kommen kann in der
durchdringung und erforschung der welt
ein forscher schritt für die menschheit
war es und sie stopft weiter ungebremst
und doch in leicht verwirrten ist
zustand so scheints nicht ganz genau
wissen wohin die reise geht
seitdem ist der schlimmste aller
schlimmste nun heilsbringer scheint
zurzeit ja dieses wunderliche wesen der
algorithmus in seiner bestimmung
eigentlich eine eindeutige
handlungsvorschläge zur lösung eines
problems nimmt seine aufgaben bierernst
kennt uns besser als wir selber löst
probleme bevor es sie gibt und setzt
einigermaßen empathie los seinen
siegeszug fort wälzt alles um stellt
alles auf den kopf
die frage wie wir die macht der
algorithmen vernünftig einsetzen ist
weit wichtiger als die wirtschaftskrise
die kriege im nahen osten oder die
flüchtlingskrise in europa die zukunft
der menschheit hängt davon ab
orakel juval havarie shooting-star der
intellektuellen und beunruhigte uns mit
einem zukunfts ratgeber der seriösen art
21 lektionen für das einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert mensch wenn das kein buch
ist für den vorsatz stapel die einst und
die null
als neue herinnen der welt die geister
die wir riefen der mensch droht ähnlich
goethes zauberlehrling die kontrolle
über seine helferlein zu verlieren
übernehmen algorithmen unsere arbeit
entschlüsseln unser fühlen und denken
nämlich dass die masse homo sapiens in
jeder hinsicht nutzlos
sagt welterklärer harari und bekam für
so viel pessimistischer weitsicht gar
eine audienz bei angela merkel nicht so
elon musk
obwohl er ähnlich drastisch warnt leute
künstliche intelligenz ist viel
gefährlicher als atomwaffen
ich halte mich wenn sie so wollen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen verzweifelt
fest an der hoffnung dass es kein
algorithmus geben würde ein ironisches
selbst verhältnis reproduzieren kaputt
und schönherr tingler aber die herren
gelehrten diese digitalisierungs panik
erschreckt der mensch wird die 1 und die
0 doch schon bändigen er hat immerhin
vor 50 jahren den mond bestiegen
apropos bestiegen das jahr in dem er 50
jahre hippies und ihre sexuelle
befreiung gefeiert haben ist vorbei
sexuell wird künftig entfesselt bis zu
unfreiheit echt immer komplizierter denn
auch da ist kollege algorithmus wieder
der kann immer liefert ständig und alles
was begehrt wird an unendliche
verfügbarkeit im netz die jugend
zugemüllt mit hohem sex noch vor den
schmetterlingen im bauch haben die
pornografie vor der nase
drei jahren ist aus funktion
gleichzeitig zum sexuellen overkill
reißt die alles durchdringende affäre
ist auch alte wunden auf entfacht von
machtspiel geilen männern angestoßen von
mutigen frauen und deren aufdeckung
sexuelle erpressungen und
vergewaltigungen folter der feuerwehr
niehuus 2018 entzündete das diffizile
gewirr aus sexuell konnotierte nötigung
missbrauch belästigung begehren lust
macht und ohnmacht
kritisches wichtiges thema wurde der
letzten jahr wurden so viel viel für ihn
aber schon immer für die generation
wichtig sondern für die man am 4
die debatte ist so wichtig wie nie ich
glaube es liegt an den strukturen die
wir einfach aufdecken benennen müssen
verändern müssen machtverhältnis sind
das großes problem auch im kulturbereich
oder gerade im kulturbereich wo es immer
noch die besetzungscouch gibt ich habe
das gefühl dass hier sehr viel
miteinander vermischt wird ich habe auch
das gefühl dass neben krassen fällen die
dokumentiert sind es auch fälle gibt von
leuten deren karriere ruiniert es
unbestritten mieter hat potenz und
landete im weltweiten ranking der
einflussreichsten figuren der kunstwelt
auf trara platz drei als bewegung zu was
gab es noch nie die skandalwelle
schäumte hoch ebbt nicht ab dringt in
jede ritze niemand wird verschont nicht
einmal die akademie für den
literatur-nobelpreis diese
traditionsbewusste bastion 2018 abgesagt
belästigung skandal die new york times
hat gezählt 200 ranghoher männer aus den
chefetagen männer aus politik medien
wirtschaft und kultur wurden allein in
den usa vom sockel gestoßen
fast die hälfte von ihnen wurde durch
frauen ersetzt apropos ausgerechnet
diese kritisieren die bewegung am
schärfsten fürchten eine neue prüderie
prophezeien das ende des flirts
schimpfen auf den moralischen
imperialismus und das tut nicht nur die
den örv mit ihrer clique nein auch
studierte philosophin mit durchaus
frauen freundlichen gedankengut da
spitzen wir die ohren
vorbei die zeit in der die frau als das
schwache geschlecht im opferstatus
verharrt
denn weder existiert sie für den mann
noch durch ihn kam und gefallsucht
streift die potente frau ab ihr zugang
zu lust ist unmittelbar sagt svenja
flaßpöhler und überhaupt wer eine welt
ohne belästigung will will in letzter
konsequenz eine welt ohne verfügung
na dann prost
apropos verführung diese beiden frauen
verführen uns definitiv zu lobeshymnen
für uns eine echte entdeckung aus der
schweizer musikszene 2018
ich bin
frauen ein schönes sein
moment stoppt frauen als männer auch
falsch eine ganz ganz neue
wissenschaftliche studie sagt jetzt wo
mehr wohlstand und gleichberechtigten
herrschen nähern sich frau und mann
nicht an im gegenteil nein da wachsen
gar die unterschiede zwischen kerl und
weiß sagt das doch gleich
ach es schmeckt keine geiss weg noch
sind bei weitem nicht alle tränen
geflossen in dieser ich auch groß
kontroversen 89 wir wissen nicht wohin
sie noch führt und ja die debatte ist
komplex und es gibt kein zurück und habe
einst ihn soll bitte bleiben wo der
pfeffer wächst wir vermissen ihn nicht
das apropos 2009 10 wird das jahr des
schweins sagen die chinesen will heißen
ein jahr voller glück ein glückliches
jahr schwein gehabt dass hunde jahr ruf
geht zur neige
übrigens hat sich eigentlich eher hier
vergraben etwa hinter seiner kochinsel
als weihnachtsmann der entsorgte
präsident quito knaden los
ausgeschrieben aus seiner serie ihn
vermissen wir zugegeben ein bisschen
unseren zynischen frank underwood er hat
den bösewicht wohl nicht nur vor der
kamera gegeben was tun wir nun mit
unseren demontierten filmhelden und vor
allem was tun die eigentlich jetzt den
lieben langen tag außer ausgefuchst ihr
comeback planen rosen schneiden
fortnight spielen oder mit schweren
augenringen am abgrund stehen
nun ein paar felsen in der brandung ein
paar unverrückbare mannsbilder werden
sich für uns auch das neue jahr kämpfen
sie werden zurück sein auf der leinwand
auf 007 müssen wir allerdings bis in den
spätherbst warten werden sie uns mit
ihrem gemecker aber je so verzaubern
können wie er das ideal des
feingeistigen modernen mannes bekannt
aus herr der ringe ein mann der sieben
sprachen spricht spielt dichtet malt und
musiziert der traummann nach motiviert
und respektvoll
naja gut in seinen neuen film der
demnächst anläuft spielte einen troll
privat aber ist er einfach toll ein mann
den wir ins herz geschlossen haben was
wir jetzt nicht dürfen ist es ausgrenzen
wiederum von männern
wir können es nur gemeinsam machen eben
gemeinsam werden wir feiern und es wird
zu feiern geben in diesem jahr nicht nur
den mann im mond nein wir feiern auch
100 jahre bauhaus die ideen schule die
sich auch als wiege des designs
bezeichnet als heimstätte der avantgarde
wir werden acht 2009/10 feiern daran
denken das vor exakt 30 jahren ja dass
es zeiten gab der mauern fielen
übrigens wussten sie dass in den letzten
jahren 45 ländern neue zäune und mauern
für ihre grenzen geplant haben
ihre gesamtlänge einmal um den erdball
aber das ist wieder eine andere
geschichte
wir werden in diesem jahr daran denken
dass exakt im jahr des mauerfalls das
www erfunden wurde und alles ganz
einfach immer etwas komplexer wurde
globaler und so ach ja das vor 30 jahren
das idyllische familienleben der
simpsons bekannt dass barbie seit 60
jahren auf ihren zehen steht und mädchen
zeigt wie man sich albern für den
männlichen blick streckt gut gehalten
baic youtube
das vor 100 jahren der acht stunden tag
für arbeiter eingeführt wurde und vor
150 jahren die postkarte und dass es ein
ganzes jahrhundert her ist als die
familie knie zum ersten mal erzählt
aufstellte ich möchte zunächst mal die
prämisse infrage stellen dass der
zustand der welt so besorgniserregend
ist er doch nicht nur herr tingler zum
beispiel nicht dann wenn mit dem
spirituellen meister mahatma gandhi
gedenken dürfen da dieser vor 150 jahren
geboren wurde oder dem universalgenie
leonardo da vinci dieser der vor 500
jahren zu tode starb und obacht
designjet und seinem fänger im roggen
dieses buch auf gewicht kult wir werden
es noch mal wieder lesen ihm zu ehren er
würde dieses jahrhundert werden übrigens
auch doris lessing und beate uhse wenn
sie noch leben würden
also man kann doch wirklich nicht sagen
der eingeprägten rollkragen pullover der
andere ein cocktailkleid können sie
sagen der eine hat geschmack der anderen
ist doch wahr oder ein gestreiftes shirt
zumindest an dem tag im frühling den wir
ganz dem kot widmen der vor einem
vierteljahrhundert vorsätzlich ins
nirwana ging
[Musik]
nevermind weil ich nicht oder briggs
gildo der vor 20 jahren von uns schied
[Musik]
ach ja ganz sicher werden uns auch im
neuen jahr ein paar welten intakt und
konstant erhalten bleiben traditionen
geben uns die sicherheit den halt die
wir nötig haben in den unbestrittenen
interessanten zeiten wie den unsrigen
meglio levin interesting times besagt
ein chinesischer fluch auf englisch na
danke aber auch motto dichten übrigens
auch die kuratoren der kommenden
kunstbiennale in venedig unsicherheit
krise und aufruhr als wäre der mensch
nicht ein gebeugter genug mischen sich
alternative fakten ins tägliche leben
und erschüttern flächendeckend das
vertrauen in ja was eigentlich politik
mediendemokratie
es ist furchtbar und so schlüpft der
mensch der verwirrte im filter blasen
rettet sich vor dem sturm von
flüchtlingswellen die angeblich bis vor
seiner haustür spaten und radikalisiert
und die gesellschaft spaltet sich auf
und ab grundsätzlich entwickelte straße
sehe ich auf der mm spaltet und klar
sich aufeinander
und das wird zu großen problemen führe
ich schon und wird nun in der hand die
tendenz einer sitzt aber die die
sichtbar mache ich vor randgruppe von
opfern oder verübt worden sind
andererseits macht zurück überhaupt
jahres ist die welt wir befinden uns
glaube ich in einer sehr kniffligen lage
gerade das ist das alles ist sehr dünn
was ich meinte für einen die populisten
bestimmen ich habe hätte nie gedacht
dass es noch mal so wichtig würde und
dass man eigentlich verstärkt jetzt
wieder ganz stark
flagge zeigen muss es geht um identität
ihres denkens sowohl von links wie von
rechts oder wer darf eigentlich an
debatten teilnehmen
und wer nicht das ist sehr wichtig finde
ich dass man darauf hinweist dass wird
immer im zusammenhang mit
rechtspopulismus erwähnt aber es gibt
auf beiden seiten des spektrums und
gerade im kulturbetrieb wirkt es dafür
dass debatten gar nicht zustande kommen
dass debatten abgewürgt werden dass
debatten verboten werden das redeverbot
erteilt werden finde dass wir haben im
prinzip einverstanden vollkommen
verloren und ich glaube dass mehr denn
je
die leute brauchen kunst die musik und
kultur und museen um geschichte und die
brauchen eine basis um durch diese
nächste zeit zu kommen
wahrlich musik und kultur bleiben uns
auch wenn die demokratie schwächelt der
fortschrittsglaube erodiert die welt
nervösen doch wächst nicht in der unruhe
eigentlich auch das interesse am denken
vernunft hilf denken gutes stichwort
folgendes hat uns im letzten jahr zu
denken gegeben
wir haben erfolglos versucht zu
verstehen warum zwei holocaust
verharmlosen der rüpel-rapper für ihre
menschenverachtende provokation auch
noch einen musikpreis nachgeworfen
[Musik]
wir haben uns gefragt wieso hochgradig
interpretations offene poesie als
sexistisch verurteilt und übermalt wird
überhaupt wir haben viel über moral und
kunst nachgedacht im letzten jahr über
die autonomie der kunst zum beispiel
darüber ob es okay ist ein künstler eine
große ausstellung zu widmen der so
scheins pädophilie stilisiert wir haben
mitgelitten als ein russisches recht
hier von den autoritäten in die
schranken gesetzt wurde und trotz allem
aus dem hausarrest bei uns eine mozart
oper inszenierte wir haben zugeschaut
wie künstlicher intelligenz bilder malt
und natürlicher intelligenz
ausgeschaltet wurde und für das werk
eine halbe million hinzublättern
echt jetzt und natürlich haben wir
geschmunzelt als minister unsichtbar
alias banksy mit seiner schredderaktion
kritik am entfesselten kunstmarkt
performte und ja nebenbei moderne kunst
geschichte schrieb und während wir über
solch verflixte momente gebrütet haben
haben wir es versäumt ihnen diese frau
hier vorzustellen
das muss an dieser stelle dringend
nachgeholt werden wäre sie nie jackpot
eine großartig unbequeme autorin die in
ihrer theologie über den randständigen
werner subindex klug und klar kritik am
neoliberalismus an bringt die die
komplexe gesellschaft auf archaische
kräfte herunterrechnet ein beispiel
dafür wie künstler helfen können zu
verstehen was auf dieser welt passiert
eine die sätze um sich schmeißt wie ich
schreibe aus dem land der hässlichen und
für die hässlichen die alten die
mannweiber die frieden die schlecht
geschickten die nicht fähig waren die
hysterischen die durchgeknallten die
frau tut gut in diesen durchtrainierten
zeiten ihre bücher unbedingt empfohlen
auf unseren vorsatz stapel und was haben
unsere gäste für vorfreude und setze ja
also jedes jahr vor
also es gibt genügend baustellen die wir
erstmal abzuarbeiten haben ist natürlich
ist persönliches highlight wenn nicht
der fünf megawatt in salzburg ist ihr
fürs neue jahr habe ich mir eigentlich
vorgenommen dass ich noch häufiger
konzerte besuchen möchte
das brauchen wir brauchen fantasie wer
ohne phantasie haben wir nur gewalt und
krieg und das kann es nicht sein die ben
und was wir definitiv auch brauchen ist
diesen ausflug per anhalter durch die
galaxie mit elon musk kirschroten
elektromobil mit einem kurzen
zwischenstopp am konzert der toten amy
winehouse als hologramm auf diese beiden
errungenschaften haben wir so sehnlichst
nicht gewartet darum schwelgen wir in
gruseliger vorfreude und hoffen sie
entpuppten sich nicht als reinfall
apropos puppen die schmetterlinge
sterben auch aus heißt es jetzt und
nostradamus hat für 2009 10 eine
plattenverschiebung angekündigt oder
aber einen gewaltigen meteoriten
einschlag oder beides wie gesagt wenn
wir die erde nicht bald verlassen sind
wir verloren und sogar dann wird das
sonnensystem irgendwann erkalten
aber lassen wir das wir bleiben jetzt
erstmal noch hier und lesen das buch zum
neuen jahr
und sollten die herren gelehrten recht
behalten dann wäre das na ja schlecht
wäre das ganz mies und traurig wäre das
weil wir könnten nie mehr mitsingen wenn
es süß in unseren ohren klingelt wir
sagen tschüss und frohes neues jahr
07 hat sich seit april sinkt ihres kind
singen sie ist wie so ne spaß am singen
[Musik]
neben einer kolumne schrieb über
registriert unter anderem frauen mit der
queen als rauber vaters in eine die das
internet sehr unhandlich uns zu sagt ist
nicht richtig dass man eben mit rollator
natürlich und es ist schwarz wie später
oder irgendwie er nicht mehr der beste
sagt rufer und heini hemmi dass die
möglichkeit und direkt noch nicht also
sie werde die mannschaft sowie titeln
oder meter große reptil erzählt sie sehr
ausführlich teil ihrer verwandtschaft
von der großmutter auf drogen und zu
bestrafen
was sagt ihr dazu sie lassen mai
geschehen offen das stück aus dem grab
haben erste da muss man sich wieder
etwas neues jahr neues glück glauben sie
ihre reinigende kraft vor beginn
der eklatante silvester ab
ich war froh sie das material überlebt
hat und das ist ein grund für jedes neue
leuchtturm 2010
jahreszeit immer wieder erfreut
das wird es auch nicht werden ja aufs
neue jahr denken dass man braucht
frühjahr stoß versetzen
[Musik]
ja wir rezensieren kein buch mehr heute
aber wir verschenken ihnen eines tante
leguan gibt es von matto kämpf wenn sie
bei uns in der verlosung mitmachen noch
neu als das buch von matto kämpf ist die
dritte staffel der comedy-serie
experiment schneuwly mit matto kämpf
bereits jetzt online bei sf ab ende
januar dann im tv-programm wir zeigen
ihnen gleich zum schluss unserer sendung
einen kleinen ausschnitt hilft
vielleicht auch gegen den januar blues
hier bei sf geht's jetzt weiter mit
einem neuen sendeplatz für serien und
den auftakt macht die dänische serie die
wege des herrn
das jahr wird gut wir sehen uns nächsten
mittwoch wieder
jetzt kommt noch die schnell ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie haben im fernsehen
[Musik]
jede funktion business dh also müsst ihr
euch ziele hat das thema baby ist auf
romina sieht große entschlossen einfach
mittelmeer uhr do zu treten oder west da
ist dass der hat sie das auch die sg bhs
mit dumping und david würde uhr neuer
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
fristlos